Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Nicoletta Pedrana
Si può essere felici senza avere figli?
Certamente sì.
Ognuno di noi è libero
di vivere la sua vita,
e il suo tempo, come vuole.
Procreare non è affatto un obbligo;
e da quando esistono gli anticoncezionali,
non è più nemmeno più un caso.
Si può scegliere di non fare bambini,
e vivere una vita piena e appagante:
my body, my choice.
La risposta è anche: no.
In effetti, diventa difficile
vivere felici senza figli
se li si desiderava, e non sono arrivati.
Alcuni riescono nel non facile
percorso dell'adozione
e dribblano così la biologia,
senza rinunciare a un'oncia
di genitorialità.
Ma c'è chi non può, non vuole,
non riesce ad adottare.
E resta senza figli,
pur avendone desiderati.
Quasi sempre si riesce
a farsene una ragione,
a incanalare altrove
tutto l'amore, e la cura,
destinati a quei figli mai arrivati.
Ma resta un dolore dentro, un rimpianto.
Dunque, alla domanda
"Si può vivere felici senza figli?"
ci sono due risposte,
e sono entrambe ugualmente valide.
Sì, se la scelta di non farne è nostra;
no, se la scelta non è dipesa da noi.
Le ricerche statistiche
dicono che, in media,
le persone in Italia
desiderano avere due figli.
Se si chiede "quanti figli vorresti?",
la media delle risposte sarà due.
Ma quanti figli fanno poi,
davvero, le persone?
Per quella bizzarria
per cui, in statistica,
i figli sono frazionabili,
la risposta a questa domanda in Italia è:
un figlio virgola venticinque.
Lo chiamano "inverno demografico",
"Denatalità".
Ha anche un impatto sull'intera società,
perché - quanti figli dovremmo fare?
Ogni paese che voglia mantenere stabile,
nel tempo, la sua popolazione
dovrebbe avere un tasso di fecondità
pari a due, anzi tecnicamente
due virgola uno.
Per ogni due genitori
che, presto o tardi, moriranno
ci saranno due figli a sostituirli.
Si chiama infatti, anche,
"tasso di sostituzione".
E ha anche un peso
negli equilibri previdenziali,
perché sono le persone in età da lavoro
a pagare, con i loro contributi,
le pensioni degli anziani.
Dunque in Italia, anziché due,
facciamo un figlio virgola venticinque.
Ma perché non facciamo
il numero di figli che desideriamo?
Uno potrebbe dire: è colpa del precariato,
degli stipendi troppo bassi.
Ed è certamente vero:
le condizioni contrattuali e retributive
spesso inadeguate,
a volte addirittura misere,
sono un forte freno al fare figli,
quantomeno nei Paesi
cosiddetti "avanzati".
Se conoscete "La Repubblica
degli Stagisti",
sapete che quella per l'equa retribuzione
è una mia battaglia da molto, molto tempo.
Però attenzione: anche in Svizzera -
che ha un mercato del lavoro florido,
quella che si dice la "piena occupazione",
e stipendi medi molto generosi -
anche in Svizzera le persone
desiderano fare due figli,
e poi però finiscono per farne molti meno:
uno virgola quarantotto.
Anche loro sono ben lontani
dal tasso di sostituzione.
L'unico Paese in Europa che è riuscito,
investendo per decenni sulla natalità,
a raggiungere il famoso due,
è la Francia.
Tutti gli altri, inverno demografico.
E allora che si fa?
Si deve spingere la gente
a fare più figli?
Obbligarla?
Colpevolizzare chi non ne fa?
Non scherziamo:
my body, my choice.
Se le persone non desiderano avere figli,
hanno il sacrosanto diritto
di non avere figli.
Bisogna lasciarle in pace.
"I figli per la patria", anche no.
Ma quello che si può e si dovrebbe fare
è permettere, a chi vuole farne, di farne!
Questa alle mie spalle è mia nonna Carmen.
La foto è degli anni Cinquanta,
e la ritrae insieme a mio nonno Gigio
e alla maggior parte dei loro figli.
Dei loro quindici figli!
Tutti nati tra il 1930 e il 1958.
Il primo quando nonna Carmen
aveva 19 anni,
l'ultima quando ne aveva quasi 49.
No, mia nonna non lavorava.
Fuori casa.
Altri tempi.
Mia madre, a cavallo
tra gli anni '70 e gli '80
ne fece due, di figli.
Io, purtroppo, una sola.
E lei, mia figlia?
Chissà se ne vorrà,
chissà quanti ne vorrà.
Chissà quanti ne farà.
Chissà quando li farà.
Eh già.
Quando.
Perché le donne, per fare figli,
hanno la cosiddetta "finestra biologica"
che va dalla prima
mestruazione alla menopausa:
indicativamente, tra i 15 e i 49 anni.
Naturalmente un figlio,
prima che quando è pronto il corpo,
bisognerebbe farlo
quando è pronta la mente:
quando ci si sente psicologicamente pronti
a prendersi cura di un altro essere umano.
Ma in realtà, i figli
si fanno, quasi sempre,
quando ci sono le condizioni per farli.
E quindi, si aspetta.
Cosa?
Uno, le condizioni economiche:
avere un tetto sopra la testa,
e di che mantenere sé stessi
e gli eventuali nascituri.
Due, le condizioni professionali:
avere un lavoro più o meno stabile,
e sopratutto non temere di poterlo perdere
per il fatto di fare il figlio.
Tre, le condizioni pratiche:
avere servizi cui affidare i propri figli
quando si torna al lavoro,
posti negli asili,
orari scolastici compatibili
con gli orari lavorativi,
possibilità di part-time.
Tutto questo combinato insieme
produce un effetto.
L'età media delle donne, al primo figlio,
è aumentata negli ultimi 25 anni,
in Italia, di quasi tre anni e mezzo.
Nel 1995 era 28 anni.
Nel 2020, 31,4.
L'età più alta di tutti i Paesi europei.
E anche l'età media
degli uomini al primo figlio
è aumentata molto, negli ultimi decenni.
Perchè quei giovani che anche si sentono
magari pronti a fare un figlio
guardano quelle condizioni,
fanno un bilancio,
e dicono: aspettiamo un attimo.
Anche le donne, malgrado il ticchettio
dell'orologio biologico,
dicono: aspettiamo.
Magari non lo dicono.
Non consapevolmente.
Ma lo fanno.
Aspettano.
Ma è giusto aspettare?
La risposta non è difficile.
È giusto se è una libera scelta:
voglio aspettare perché
non mi sento ancora pronta;
perché non ho ancora trovato
la persona giusta
con cui cui mi vada di fare una famiglia;
perché ho voglia di fare prima
il giro del mondo.
Perché voglio concentrare
tutta la mia energia
sul mio lavoro, o sulla mia passione,
senza distrazioni.
Sono scelte personali, private.
Insindacabili.
Giuste.
Non va bene, invece, aspettare
se aspettare fa soffrire.
Se si vorrebbe un figlio adesso,
ma adesso non si può.
Perché le colleghe che diventano mamme
vengono sistematicamente demansionate,
o addirittura licenziate.
Perché la lista d'attesa
per gli asili di zona è infinita,
e quelli privati costano troppo.
Perché invariabilmente il messaggio
che arriva dall'esterno è:
"Aspetta. Aspetta il contratto
a tempo indeterminato.
Compra casa, intanto.
Aspetta, che fretta hai?".
Che fretta hai.
Prima ho detto che le donne
hanno la finestra biologica,
dalla prima mestruazione alla menopausa,
per fare figli.
Teoricamente è vero.
La scienza però ci dice
che la fertilità della donna
è massima tra i 20 e i 30 anni,
e subisce un calo repentino
già intorno ai 35-37.
Le probabilità che ha una donna
che ha rapporti, e non prende precauzioni,
di restare incinta
sono prossime allo zero, in realtà,
già diversi anni prima della menopausa.
È un po' un paradosso.
Per quanti passi avanti abbia fatto l'uomo
nella sua evoluzione,
il sistema riproduttivo femminile
è rimasto pressoché identico
a com'era 200 anni fa,
oppure 2000 anni fa.
Oggi le donne studiano, come gli uomini.
Lavorano, come e più degli uomini.
Si sposano più tardi,
o non si sposano affatto.
Eppure, il nostro corpo non si è adeguato
a questo nuovo orizzonte.
La finestra biologica, sostanzialmente,
non si è spostata in avanti.
E dunque "che fretta hai?"
è un trabocchetto. Un inganno.
Si pensa, a 30 anni,
di avere tutto il tempo del mondo.
Ma non si ha tutto il tempo del mondo.
La verità è che cominciare
a cercare i figli tardi
può comportare - non sempre,
ma può - molte difficoltà.
C'è più probabilità di dover ricorrere
alle tecniche di fecondazione assistita,
che però hanno una percentuale
di risultato positivo -
il cosiddetto "bimbo in braccio" -
solamente intorno al 30 percento;
e questa percentuale crolla
non appena la donna scavalla i 40 anni.
Ci sono più probabilità
di aborti spontanei,
o di concepire figli
con problemi di salute.
La vita intima delle coppie,
qualche volta,
viene fortemente messa alla prova
dai rapporti sessuali "a comando",
che sono necessari
per i tentativi di concepimento.
E l'altra verità
è che le donne non lo sanno
finché non ci si trovano in mezzo.
A 20 anni, a 30 anni
non ci preoccupiamo
della nostra fertilità,
se non in senso inverso:
prendere anticoncezionali
per non restare incinta.
Ma quando invece si tratta
di restare incinta,
arriviamo impreparate -
Ma come, ci stiamo provando
già da tre mesi e ancora niente?
Che succede?
Anch'io sono arrivata impreparata.
Non avevo idea di quanto più flebile fosse
la probabilità di rimanere incinta
a 38 anni, piuttosto che a 28.
Non avevo idea del fatto
che la qualità degli ovuli delle donne
si deteriorasse con l'età.
Non sapevo che, dei quattro figli
che avrei desiderato,
ne avrei fatta soltanto una.
È fantastica, eh. Ma è figlia unica.
La verità è che cominciare
a cercare i figli tardi
è uno dei principali fattori
che fa aumentare il divario
tra figli desiderati e figli avuti.
E allora è tempo di dirci:
perché aspettare?
È tempo di una grande battaglia sociale
per rivendicare il diritto a fare figli
quando li desideriamo, e non
quasi fuori tempo massimo -
perché indotti ad attendere
dalle pressioni del lavoro,
dalle difficoltà della conciliazione,
dall'impressione di essere
sole contro il sistema.
Una rivoluzione culturale per ribadire
che i figli si fanno in due,
almeno nella maggior parte dei casi.
E quindi ci vuole una genitorialità
realmente condivisa:
congedi di maternità
e di paternità paritari;
Un uguale investimento
delle madri e dei padri
nelle attività di genitori
che venga riconosciuto pubblicamente,
a cominciare dal mondo del lavoro.
E questa, anche se non sembra,
è una battaglia anche politica.
Perché poter fare figli
è l'inverso di poter non fare figli.
E se allora crediamo,
come io fortemente credo,
nei diritti riproduttivi e sessuali.
Se inorridiamo di fronte
alla pratica delle spose bambine.
Se ci indigniamo quando leggiamo
che ci sono ancora parti di mondo
in cui, quando alle bambine
vengono le mestruazioni,
devono smettere di andare a scuola,
perché a quel punto
il loro destino è segnato,
e devono cominciare a fare il loro lavoro,
che è sposarsi e fare figli.
Se sosteniamo il diritto
alla pianificazione familiare,
perché ovunque, nel mondo,
uomini e donne possano avere
anticoncezionali sicuri e accessibili.
Se perfino oggi, nei nostri
Paesi evoluti e laici,
ci ritroviamo di nuovo a dover combattere
per il diritto all'interruzione
di gravidanza legale e sicura,
altro pilastro dei diritti
riproduttivi e sessuali.
My body, my choice.
Allora è tempo che proprio da qui,
dai nostri Paesi economicamente avanzati,
ma colpiti dall'inverno demografico,
parta una battaglia perché questi diritti,
che mettono al centro
l'importanza di poter scegliere
il momento, e il numero, dei figli,
non si declinino soltanto
in una censura delle gravidanze
troppo precoci, o troppo frequenti,
nei Paesi in via di sviluppo.
C'è anche un altro modo
di declinare questi diritti,
il modo inverso:
voglio fare figli a 25 anni,
a 28 anni, a 30 anni.
Non voglio aspettare.
E non è giusto che sia così difficile,
che sia una scelta così osteggiata.
È un tema che riguarda tutti.
Anche gli uomini -
anche se loro possono fare figli
più o meno a qualsiasi età:
ma attenzione, non certo
con la stessa compagna.
Il cammino per il cambiamento sociale
funziona così: si cammina,
anche se l'obiettivo non riguarda
personalmente ciascuno di noi.
Perché ci riguarda come società.
Come esseri umani che cercano
di costruire un mondo più giusto.
Un mondo in cui alla domanda
"Perché hai aspettato
così tanto per fare figli?"
ci sia in futuro una sola risposta:
"Perché l'ho scelto io, liberamente."
Avendo ben chiare tutte le informazioni.
Senza avere subito pressioni.
Perché magari prima non ne desideravo,
e dopo invece sì.
Un mondo più giusto,
in cui le persone possano avere figli
se li desiderano, quando li desiderano,
e se hanno fortuna,
senza dover più aspettare.
(Applausi)